now why is your day back we thought he
got [ __ ] t-boned and nearly died this
past weekend in Chicago you know what
they say when you get hit an accident
everything slows down yeah it actually
does uh-huh but everything's a blur he
has a huge welt on his leg and he showed
me the wreck and it was I who was
driving it was a hit-and-run so yeah I
didn't know you were driving your own
car rental car which isn't [ __ ] work
okay so you're driving a rental car and
somebody hit you from behind
no no they hit me front passenger side
so I spun at 180 they basically ran a
red light they hit me on the right I
spun and they took off some guy was just
like yo like I just took off you dead
man the car I don't know why I was
telling you I got it are so angry
because of adrenaline I had to kick the
door was stuck I kept yelling it was
just raining yeah and I just found out
the guy wasn't there and Gilbert if you
died we would be shattered beyond repair
I went here Bobby said devastated I I'm
gonna crash no I'm trying to figure out
how I feel no I'm not being real I want
to do the most honest thing okay tell me
that Gilbert died an accident yeah I
just got a text from who from Gilbert's
mom who's that babe Gilbert Gabriel okay
bro the guy on a third money oh yeah
yeah he's cool he died Gilbert's mom
died no Gabriel Gilbert himself himself
died yes
and then what what happened what else so
many questions yeah that made me feel
weird doing that I don't actually want
to do that yeah it's not gonna ever
[ __ ] happen I never want to actually
ever say that that's but I used to
always say I'll never get an accident I
never been an accident I've been in a
million's that's a part of life yeah he
hit and runs I hit run I've been running
ahead like small hit serious like he
hits there it's a far away if it's a
bumper to bumper and it's a
my person oh you you can't hit my BMW
right and they pull over I just drive by
you're good
it's stupid even today lie I don't say
hi I just gotta memorize my license
plate I'd rather go to prison I'll be
real alright but you didn't die and I
don't know what you're saying okay
[Music]